I have to give Jon Jones credit for I'm
really doing that pains me I gotta give
him credit here because people have said
he was gonna fight Stipe and then he's
going to retire it's like well hold on
people let me remind you of one thing
when you talk about the mindset you talk
like Jon Jones doesn't have the courage
let me just remind you to be fair he
thought he was fighting Francis he
agreed to fight Stipe and he ended up in
there with surreal so when he is surreal
which is a pretty favorable matchup he
had agreed to Francis and he had agreed
to Stipe Jon Jones isn't going anywhere
and if the steepe Goes Up in Smoke he's
already said I'll fight the next best
thing you decide who it is
one of the reasons I want you on the
show I want your opinions you know I you
know you're my favorite person to talk
to about this stuff when it comes to uh
when it comes to the pfl I'm not being a
hater and and I'm getting a lot of
pushback on this and they're like oh
you're just pushing you know the UFC you
know boat there and you're just riding
on Dana's coattails I'm not I'm as a
businessman nowhere near to the level of
Dana White but as a businessman if I
take out my bias towards I love uh
Francis absolutely great dude we've had
him on the show amazing his agent Markel
did wonders for him when I look at the
deal I go well this is a great deal for
Francis this is a terrible deal for the
pfl and I can see why Dana decided not
to make the deal because again take out
let's say you didn't know Francis
take out whatever admiration you have
for Francis 36 years old coming off a
major knee surgery
he's never been a big pay-per-view star
never been a big pay-per-view star and
also he's not that active whether it's
the UFC's issue or Francis doesn't
matter the point is he's not that active
so it's kind of like yeah we can let
this guy go and then also you know the
contract came out I think Nick sick said
this they offered him eight million to
fight Jon Jones that makes sense eight
mil and that makes all the sense that
fight's gonna do gangbuster numbers then
after and does he is he is he favorable
to win that fight absolutely not so the
chances are the odds are he's gonna lose
that fight then after that you have
Sergey waiting for him you got the
Almeda monster out there who would be a
rough matchup so I'm with the UFC on
this they're like we're good man and
when I look at the deal and people give
me pushback it's like Francis did his
thing we've never seen a deal like this
that's amazing good for him I don't
think it's gonna work out history would
be on my side I don't see how pfl is
going to bring on the talent to sell a
pay-per-view which they've never had a
successful pay-per-view model and I'm
not being a hater I hope it works out I
just don't see it name a matchup that
you can give me right now that the pfl
could sign up free agent that you're
gonna pay whatever 59.99 for I don't see
it
yeah and and let me tell you Scott
coker's uh Bellator
um
it was it was Mike Hogan representing uh
Scott Coker belt over they went on they
met with Francis they went to Las Vegas
they had lunch with him and kogan even
said look I didn't want this guy to ruin
my dinner so I booked him for lunch it
was on Super Bowl Sunday they go out and
they sit down and for 25 minutes Francis
just spoke and kogan really liked him he
really liked him so he was a real
peaceful guy
um at a real good sense but he just said
Francis for the numbers that you're
talking you're going to need a
pay-per-view model and he said so I'm
not going to waste your time and we'll
let you waste ours we're not going to
give you an offer and Bellator never did
put an offer forward for Francis once
they heard him they just realized this
isn't going to work and then kogan tried
to to smarten Francis up and just say
look
people can't figure out why their
pay-per-views don't work and they even
use Bellator as an example told them
everything that they did everything they
put behind them they had fade on throw
myself in there and fan Phil Davis and
uh you know mitrione and uh you know
Bader and Aaron Pico really put a good
car together went to Madison Square
Garden got 15 million dollars infused by
Paramount and kogan shares these numbers
with it he told him that and he said we
never went back to pay-per-view and he
said the one thing the pay-per-view
needs you have to have time you cannot
come in on a one-off you can't do like
Tito and Chuck and when Tito and Chuck
bombed that didn't mean that Golden Boy
was gonna bomb it you just but you got
to start the UFC already did that
they've already started they've got a
successful model now I only share that
with you because he was just trying to
let him know for these numbers are for
what you want to achieve you need to
make up what
and you need to go back and that was
what he left him with so Bellator
actually told him hey go go sign with
these guys they're treating you pretty
good I bring that to you because I'm a
miss that is always made by Fighters
always is I am the best
I am the best and I'll make your show
better when I tell you they miss that
what a promoter is going to buy is for
sure what makes my show better but
they'll also pay to not let somebody
else's show be very good yep so so what
I'm saying is Bellator would want to
take Francis but they would want it more
so the UFC couldn't have him just by
example so if you're Francis and you're
coming off the shelf to your point I
don't know that he's 37 years old I know
he's at least 37 years old I don't know
how good those records are I truly do
mean that and he's got the knee injury
and those things aren't great but if you
find out that he's gonna sit for another
year he's not going to go out there
you now aren't paying for the second
thing a guy will pay for which is to
stop somebody else's product if he's not
on anybody's Channel I'm good with that
right and that's the one thing that
Francis and everybody else misses if I'd
like him on my channel if he's going to
be on one of yours if he's not going to
be on any of yours we're all good yeah
that's why St Peter who retired doesn't
start taking a whole bunch of offers
people are fine as big a star as he was
if you're not going on anyone's Network
we're good let's move on to the next one
that's a missing point I hope I said
that clearly but if you want something
that was a little odd within Francis you
know if you're the pfl you're going to
go out and buy something like by example
pfl has never got featured on uh the ESP
into something called the car wash but
it's where they run you out there you go
from one station to the next one show to
the next this is really great thing
they've never got that if they could get
a car wash that's worth something maybe
even a million dollars Believe It or Not
Francis can't do that this isn't
breaking news they didn't break into
sports center Jim Rome didn't stop what
he was doing you didn't stop what you're
doing here we are two weeks late doing
it Dan Le batard didn't invite him on
him is one of these things where hey
guys what exactly are you buying I'm
very open to it and I would like you to
win but what are you buying and I love
the point that you made I'm sure to be
worried on wordy on this but to go back
to what you said you talked about he
wasn't a big pay-per-view draw he fought
surreal gone now that is the single
greatest storyline in Heavyweight
Championship history they both had a
bell right this is Hogan versus Warrior
as they walk out there everything's
great they used to be training Partners
there was a split up they were
countrymen uh this coach stayed with
surreal knew the secrets of Francis
you're not going to beat that and they
bombed they fell flat on their face they
didn't even talk about rematching that
or they got done with that and they
turned and ran and I just bring it to
you because I don't know what's next for
Francis but I guarantee it won't be as
big and it won't be as juicy as surreal
which bombed agree yeah it and that's my
whole point it's again I'm not
discrediting France what he got done
it's great all I'm saying as a business
with the UFC I can see how they're like
we're good we're good you're making all
these crazy demands we're good we want
to do the Jon Jones fight that's where
we're gonna make our money but after
that it gets dicey for you and I think
for Francis for him to label this a
success the pfl things a whole other
issue that they're going to have to
figure out and there's no stars to sign
to sell that pay-per-view and to your
point they're not known as a
pay-per-view model so that's another
Hill they have to climb the I think for
Francis to say look look you see I made
the right decision he has to get that
big boxing fight and there's absolutely
no momentum that proves that that's
going to come out because they're
basically paying them now to I guess
train for boxing if he's not final next
year so I guess these focused on boxing
right now and Anthony or Anthony Joshua
came out was like ah I'm not gonna do
that circus act I'm out man Fury you
know he wants the USIC fight that's what
he that that's what his goal is he has
another fire to put out with that so
he's not focused on Francis Deontay
Wilder we haven't heard much he seemed
like the Deontay Wilder is gonna be the
closest one who's gonna maybe take a a
bite of that and jump into the Francis
pool but there's no there's again
there's no smoke there there's no smoke
and Eddie is you know he's a promoter
and a businessman but for the most part
he really does have a history of being
pretty straight with you he really
doesn't say things just yeah according
to Eddie Hearn you got you got Tyson uh
it's Tyson and usick are tied up but
you've also got Joshua and Wilder
they're going to go over to the Middle
East and do that card I I personally
believe that only because Eddie said it
he said it a couple of times not to
mention he wasn't looking to to promote
it he was just going to manage and
that's how he's going to make his speech
I just believed it and I understand it
because Wilder did make a commitment to
Francis online it was through Twitter
but he never looked like he was going to
follow up on that and so I you know I
have sat here and wondered hey is
Francis playing this right does Francis
have the next big hand is Frances versus
Wilder a big match like you know Conor
and Mayweather first off didn't do near
the business that they claimed that it
did but secondly
um it wasn't just Conor it was a
simultaneous two division UFC champion
with Dana White being a Carnival Barker
in his corner correct and this is wildly
different Francis is the UFC champion
fighting Tyson is very different just by
example I'll say Tyson it's very
different than Francis the former UFC
champion who's 37 years old at least and
coming off a knee injury fighting Tyson
in a sport that they just made up the
rules because he's never done it before
maybe it starts to get weird dude it
starts to get weird fast
and and I'll ask you this channel if
when Francis was sitting down with Dana
if someone before he went into that
office and met with Dana if someone went
to Francis hey man
the Tyson Fury thing probably not gonna
happen
the the big boxing thing it's not
looking good let's hope but it is a long
shot dude have fun you know now go
negotiate I wonder if Francis knew going
into his negotiations with Dana if he
knew that this boxing fight wasn't gonna
happen come to fruition if he would have
had a different kind of attitude going
into that meeting
yeah yeah Brenda and vice versa what
what if Damon knew it wasn't gonna
happen I I think and I I got to use the
word think I'm only as good as the
information I've read online but I think
that all Francis wanted was a carve out
I don't think he told Dana and Hunter
hey you have to get me no I don't think
they were involved I think he just
wanted a carb out if I have an
opportunity to do this and fury himself
says that you know he's going to choose
me they brought me over to England there
was 93 000 people we seemed to get a
good reception if I have that
opportunity I got to take it can we all
agree can we actually write that down
they might have done it but man it it
kind of felt like for a while something
was going to happen I mean again Tyson
Fury said himself they got France is
there they put him you know before they
fade into black and rolled the credit
right there on ESPN whose partners with
Dana and something else they kept a
secret from Dan it looked like they were
gonna go out and do something here and
then they even were talking about uh
playing the same venue that the Raiders
play and coming out to Vegas I mean
there was some real talk I'll tell you
one thing I was surprised about Brennan
is what little power Tyson Fury had I
would have thought in that space if
Tyson Fury promises 93 000 live people
and says I want this guy that he could
have talked to Eddie that he could have
got this done I was a little bit
surprised how quick they blew that off
and I got to make the same point because
Deontay Wilder does seem like a
reasonable uh Prospect or chance for
Francis only in that much like Tyson
he's personally spoken and said that he
would do it the other side of that he's
in the same territory
Wilder went and became a free agent now
he thought all the promoters would look
at that and go how cool was that he left
this guy now but that's not how they
look at it they go back to what I was
telling you at the very beginning
I would like you because you make my
product better but if nobody has you
you're not on any we're good because
this is competition right I don't need
to be better than I used to be I just
got to be better than you each time so
it's it's really one of those spots and
I think it was a Miss by Deontay let's
take a little break from chatting with
my absolute favorite Channel sewn and
coming with some heat a few tour dates
and we'll get right back to the episode
I'm in La Jolla The Comedy Store right
outside San Diego that is June 2nd
through the 4th that's two shows Friday
two shows Saturday one show Sunday your
boys working on the Lord's day that's in
La Jolla California The Comedy Store
again right outside San Diego so come
get you some of my favorite venues and
then after that the tour really ramps up
because your boys jumping across the
pond this is a theater run one show in
every city in a theater June 15th I
start in Belfast the United Kingdom
Belfast then I'm in Glasgow then I'm in
Manchester June 18th June 22nd I'm in
London June 23rd Cardiff and then I end
the Europe tour in my fave Dublin
Ireland June 25th come get you some all
right this episode of one-on-one would
be job with Chael Sonos brought to you
by
coldra lab that's right say goodbye to
the generic face wash on your counter
because cauldron lab is here to save the
day when it comes to your skin backed by
Leading clinical trial where nine out of
10 Bros experience healthier invisible
improved skin your boys looking at my
skin is popping I love their eye cream I
put it under the bags on my eyes they
look like nuts whatever all right so if
you use code shop at cauldronlab that's
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-lab.com for twins off
their best products cauldron lab creates
high performance men's skin care
products by combining pharmaceutical
grade science along with Nature's Pierce
and most potent ingredients kicking off
their skin care selection they have all
sorts they have the bundle inside this
bundle you get the Clean Slate the base
layer and the good the Clean Slate is
where you start your day it's bouncing
cleanser that use gentle plant-based
cleansing leaving all skin types looking
pretty fresh the base layer is a
nutrient dense fortifying moisturizer
that hydrates your skin absorbs fast
leaving you with a matte finish so you
don't look all juicy on your face the
good is that go to night before bed
clinical proven multifunctional serum
that helps your skin look Tighter and
smoother so get you some man get rid of
those crow's feet the wrinkles all over
your face we got you covered man all
right so get 20 off with the code shop
at cauldronlab.com that's
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-lab.com that swimsoft at
calderlab.com by using the code shop
unlock your youthful glow and be ready
for the summer with cauldron lab now
let's get back to talking to my friend
gel sonen agree I think uh the other
point nobody's talking about and it came
out how much money the UFC made last
year you know I think uh in you know
what they made over 200 million profit
this is probably I've paid all the
employees the venues everything that
they're involved in you're talking about
over 200 million profit in a calendar
year which is the most any Combat Sports
organization's ever made boxing MMA
whatever it's the most money any
company's ever made in the history of
fighting so when I see that
there is something to it where it's like
they could they could if they if they
really wanted that fight to happen or
any fights happen for that matter they
have the money to do it and you're
looking at they're paying out the
fighters about a 13 you know out of out
of that profit so can they pay Fighters
more absolutely it could they could they
make the Francis Tyson Fury fight happen
if they truly want to absolutely could
we have gotten the Jon Jones Francis
fight a year ago absolutely they have
the money to do it they're just not
willing to play that game I don't think
they want to set that standard and then
have to Fork over whatever comparable to
MLB or NBA 50 of their profits and again
do I wish do if I'm Dana it do do I wish
Dana would pay the fighters more
absolutely that'd be great but again as
a business if I'm Dana I'm doing exactly
how he's doing it I'm going why where
else you guys going gonna go what are
you gonna do I'm I'm the iPhone of
fighting go go over to go over to
Cricket Wireless go over to freaking you
know who whoever else is run the same
scheme go over to Android phones let me
know how it goes for you it ain't Apple
so we don't have to make a change yeah
no and I really appreciate you saying
that uh that was that was probably hard
for you because it was kind of a
compliment uh today that was that was
probably a little bit painful but I got
to tell you I really appreciate that you
said it because I read that same article
you're talking about and they were doing
a juxtaposition to fight or pay versus
revenue and in all fairness fighter pay
didn't go down it it wanted you to
believe it with that it didn't actually
go down the fighters were each making
more revenues got so big and the
pandemic ended up being great for
business for the UC who would have
predicted that I mean we've always been
led to believe that they're in the live
gate and pay-per-view business they
don't win an entire year without a
single person no live gain at all we've
always thought it was live gaining pay
for no live gain at all and he turns in
higher revenues than he ever did before
so we need to start learning okay
there's a different game being played
here but as we talk about that Daniel's
learning that too when Dana was a street
kid from Boston and he got in the
business he thought he needed people to
show up and buy a live ticket he needed
people to watch a closed caption from
their living room that's what he thought
he didn't know this was a sponsorship
game he didn't know this was video games
you know he just didn't understand there
was rights buys and television deals
something out there called digital that
didn't exist when he started in 2001 so
as the revenues got big I mean I thought
that article was very unfair because it
tried to lead you to believe that they
were paying less and that's not what
happened they they made more Matt mitrio
taught me something years ago Matt
mitrione was one of the few guys that
when he got to deal in the UFC he got in
front of Lorenzo not many people did yep
why Matt Mitchell did I don't know
Lorenzo had a few though like he Dan
Hardy I mean he had a few guys that were
real close to us
yeah it was a close one but Mitch real
sat with him and he said I want a half a
million dollar signing bonus and Lorenzo
said you know what what are you talking
about Matt that that's bigger than your
whole contract and Matt said no the
signing bonus and he explained from the
NFL standpoint Metro said no it's not
it's not moving forward it's this moving
forward he said the signing bonus is for
you to make up for what happened over
here for for the five fights that I've
already done that were a little bit
short business got good houses filled up
that's what the signing bonus is for and
Lorenzo listened to that and I don't
think they came to that number but they
came to a pretty good number and Lorenzo
also told him hey I want to know the
football model my son's got aspirations
of football if someone's playing at uh
Notre Dame at the time Lorenzo said I
didn't know that that's what it's done
and so anyway I'm just saying that Mitch
realm kind of said something and
everybody learned a little bit and there
seems to be when we do learn in this
business they want to write an article
and hold it against Dana it's like man I
learned something we brought in some
good revenues what do you want me to do
the world changed they took all my gate
away but I found a way good for me I
agree and I think the the really the
message should be
what a badass Dana White is when every
every other sport every other
Corporation is shutting down and then he
goes I'm gonna figure out how to keep
this business rolling I don't know how
I'm gonna do it and then he gets his
feather up his ass and goes oh I'm gonna
do it in the Middle East I'm gonna go
over to Dubai where the hell they did it
I'm gonna do it there people like you're
out of your mind fight Island this
thing's a major success and then he has
the balls you go all right we're coming
back to America because we're kind of
opening up I'm gonna do it just at the
Apex Center so we don't have to move the
whole circus we'll just do it here this
is easy we'd have to pay for all the
hotels and all the stuff we own all this
we'll do it here it you know you got to
give them as flowers man you have I
don't it's not enough of that's out
there because he is who he is and you
know he does do some outlandish things
but as far as the business goes you got
to give it up to a man and that article
I agree was kind of more of a hit piece
but if there's some things where you
look at go man that guy knows what the
hell he's doing when it comes this fight
business hey I what you just said
talking about the business here because
this is another side that the 32 year
old Street kid from Boston had no idea
about and that is these travel
advisories every state has it the whole
reason the UFC doesn't go to Hawaii is
Hawaii has a tourism board and
commission and the UFC wants six million
dollars to come Brendan nobody knew that
was a thing I did not know that you
could get paid by a state to come I
thought you went there had the state
regulate you gave them six percent and
it's a fast anything because what data
was able to work out in the Middle East
and fight Island he secures an island
but they paid him to come yeah and they
Justified it they it was a lot of
advertisements you watched it you really
wanted to go to Dubai you realize what a
beautiful place it was I mean there was
a trade here but that was just a side of
the business that nobody even knew
existed I think that that includes Dana
until he got in that situation had to
look around and by the way you bring up
the Apex why if I took over the UFC on
my first day I'm going to tell the CEO
you need to prove to me why we go on the
road I want to see financially why we go
on the road I know people talk about
well this is how you build a market this
is how you grow it said that could be
true but I know that the Patriots didn't
have to do that to sell their Arena I
know Saturday Night Live which is the
biggest longest standing show in the
world has never left New York I'm not
really sure that I'm convinced that you
have to move physically around you can
just bring those people well if I want
an Asian market I gotta go to Asia no
you just need to bring in an Asian guy
and then tell the market I think I think
this is what I would argue so I really
like the way the businesses and done
lately I like the idea that there's a
set Arena I like the way that they do
the Apex and people are comfortable and
know their way around and I don't mind
watching on TV either I got to remind
you the Apex is where we saw steepe
versus DC part three that was great my
only pushback on the Apex is if we're
going to go towards that business model
and you're gonna have like this home
field out based on if UFC's home base is
out of Vegas which it is and you're
gonna go that route
let's let's build it like the Raiders
stadium make it freaking phenomenal
because they could sell that bad boy out
like you put on the right fights I mean
you're talking there's no off season
dude so think if you built the NFL hey
every Sunday or once once a month you
can basically have the Super Bowl every
freaking month and it's gonna be in the
same location dude it I mean it'd be
insane my only pushback with the Apex I
know for the fighters a lot of them it's
not it doesn't feel as special you know
the crowd's smaller you know it's not as
nice you're not getting the bells and
whistles the press conferences stuff
like that but I think for the UFC I love
it let's do it here have your home field
there and but you got to build that
thing out just that the Apex is nice but
it's not math Square Garden you know
it's not yeah you know Staple Center
oh I I fully agree with that um they've
gone back to Vegas they just did this
about a month ago but they went to the
Hard Rock yeah I like it was kind of a
head scratcher going wait a minute why
did you rent the Apex and I think the
answer was yes they rented the Apex out
but it was seeing like why'd you rent it
out if you were I mean it was the whole
thing was just answered I would like to
know the back story I find that stuff I
think it was the slap Fight League
oh is that what it was yeah I'm pretty
sure they're booked up with a slap fight
leak and listen for all the great things
Dana has done we can't just you know
Jack them off on here I gotta give him a
little push back that slap Fight League
when I look at that I'm like oh he's
bored he's just bored this is like he's
just bored with fighting at this point
like you know damn well that's not
that's not good dude and then when he
has to defend himself like what crush is
on Tick Tock I'm like soda beheadings
from Isis dude like you want to start
that business like there's a reason why
just because it goes viral on Tick Tock
doesn't mean it's going to be a business
on TV and he learned that the hard way
but what I do love about him is it's
very trumpish where once he's in he's
gonna fight tooth and nail there's no
going back and I appreciate it like he
just doubles down on it like these guys
are real athletes I'm like bro I just
saw a guy weigh in at over 400 pounds in
need of Snickers on the weighing scale
bro quit pushing this narrative but he
just does it and I I enjoy it it's funny
me I do too I'm with you and I thought
this I thought he was fooling when he
started with this I thought he was
around and he started giving numbers
though right I mean by Fighter's line
promoters like but numbers don't lie and
their numbers on Tick Tock are insanely
successful and I will tell you that's
where I've seen most of it I I didn't
know there was multiple leagues and
apparently there's one in Russia there's
two or three here in the states Tim
Sylvia just did a slap fight I assumed
that was Dana's so I'm just finding out
no no there's a whole bunch of promoters
and a whole bunch of people doing it
okay fine by the way my only point to
Brandon is that's where I watch I I
watched on Tick Tock in in eight to 15
seconds at a time I have enjoyed it on
there I enjoy the comments it's quick
and I move through I don't know that I
want to sit and watch a whole uh
television show of it and I haven't yet
but I'm gonna only bring it to you that
he is exploding on Tick Tock I don't
know who that market is or where in the
world young kids come from but when Dana
says how big they are over there he's
he's not lying it's true they're huge on
Tick Tock yeah no he's not lying it's
just I don't think he can take a 15
second clip into turn to it like you
don't want listen like I'll watch 15
seconds of anaconda eating an alligator
I don't watch a 60 Minute show of
anacondas eating alligators you know
what I'm saying like I I tuned in
because it was just a complete [__] show
I tuned in for I think four episodes and
then because my my wife Joe she was
laughing at she's like this is real
she's like this is an actual show I'm
like yeah and so every Wednesday we'd
watch and laugh our asses off and then
after about four episodes she's like I
think I'm good I'm good on the slap
Fight League I was like yeah I get it
whoa hey what about them getting hit I
mean the commission comes in I the
commission I think got more slappers
than they got pfl and they got a whole
roster of pfl guys I thought that was
interesting though for a completely
different regard I mean when's the last
time we've heard of the novice Nevada
State athletic commission flagging an
athlete for being dirty and largely
because who Sada stepped in we act as
though that's just who saw this thing
now but the commission's budget has not
gone down neither has their regulations
nor their rules they are supposed to be
testing just as many people you don't
ever hear of it so I didn't think there
was a little bit of it you turn your
head into okay slap and pfl got hit
meanwhile Conor McGregor with rumors is
in your state right now doing The
Ultimate Fighter I mean Keith Kaiser
tested this and made it very clear you
have the right to test an athlete not
once he's licensed you have the right to
test an athletes once a fight is
announced and they announced Conor
McGregor versus Chandler we've got all
these rumors that McGregor was there in
Nevada they can't leave the state line
but they can test them anytime they want
it and they in it yeah but that's just a
dangerous game you would not come there
if you were in fact I mean it was a
really weird thing and they should have
gone in and tested me either cleared the
rumors and cleared Conor's name or go
the other way but they should have test
them they had the right to test them
they chose to not test them that's
selective testing that's a problem for
me if I'm the pfl I'm the pfl you got a
big problem guys
first of all I'll get to the Connor
stuff but with with the pfl why are we
testing these guys I want them on meth
and steroids if I want to see them slap
each other like the more the merrier I
assume they're all on cocaine why do you
test them they're in rash guards with
tits right but with Connor they they
were smart because they never they they
announced it but they there's no date so
there's no official announcement and I
think that's the the brilliant uh game
planning of the UFC brass going let's
announce it but leave it open let's
leave it up because to your point if we
do give a date the commission's income
sniffing around or that's why they did
it it's brilliant I think the fight
happens you're right that is brilliant I
never saw it until you just set it down
right now that that's a really good
point and maybe that is uh maybe that is
why they did it quite frankly when Keith
Kaiser did this had this gone to court I
don't think he is the would have won if
you're not licensed I don't think you
have the right but vandelay vandelay and
I both were I went down but vandely got
a lifetime ban he got I mean he never
could fight in the UFC again it ended up
being a four-year ban um he was able to
compete again but it was a different
organization Bellator just to remind you
of that story though so out of
competition testing usada we all know
what those things are now Brennan but
vandelay and I were the first ones ever
tested we did not know usada was
involved and we didn't know without a
competition testing was like those words
were things that didn't exist within our
space yeah so they go to vandelay's gym
and they want him to present himself
right USANA watches you they want him to
present himself naked and pee into a cup
and Bailey's going but I don't know who
you are and vanity didn't have a license
uh and the guy says why was do Sonic
give some paperwork wants him to sign it
and then present his naked self and
vanity said no he said wait till my
attorney gets down here and family had
to go now where I had to go was to be on
TV with Fox at the time to come into our
press conference so he did that's where
he went so they said he plead he's like
well I don't know if I agree with that I
don't know that you flee your gym to go
to the UFC where absolutely everybody is
and that's what he did he said I don't
understand you talk to my attorney I'm
not doing this he came to the press
conference they said he ran and refused
the test they gave him a four year ban
and you know Mandalay got so mad he was
screaming and yelling he started put out
these rock and roll videos but if he
would have just stayed calm and explain
that story I don't think that that would
have held up and I only say that to you
because if the commission was to go to
Conor and Connor was to say it's not
announced you don't have the right or he
was to say I'm not licensed you don't
have the right it's the same thing that
Mandalay did I mean a no is a no yeah
and they give them a four-year ban for
refusing the test and this is before
we've even heard what who sought or up
at a competition it was a very very
strange thing uh I don't think vandalee
should have been punished for it I think
if he would have stayed calm and told
the story that I just told you he
wouldn't have been punished for it but
it's just it's just an interesting point
you'll remember the time that the UFC
they did an entire heavyweight card all
five of the main card fights were going
to be heavyweights so they make this
announcement they hold the press
conference Kaiser comes in and tests
everybody there Overeem hits the back
gets in the car and leaves they call him
they have him come back and that was and
Rheem got flagged on that but Rheem had
a pretty good point which is man
I'm not with you guys and that's where
Kaiser said nope if a fight is announced
and you're in my state line I've got the
right and they let they let that hold
boy yeah you guys had especially you
vandelay Overeem God bless you man you
guys have to learn the hard way
unfortunately you know hopefully
Fighters learn from it today which I
think Conor is playing the game I think
that what makes Connor pretty damn
special is his IQ with this the the
business side and the fight side
speaking of Connor did you see the
documentary
no I heard all about it I look forward
to seeing it but no I haven't I haven't
seen it yet man it's good it is so good
I was saying how I watched it and I got
I got sad I got sad at the end because I
don't think we'll ever see that again
not in my lifetime of just that it was
the perfect timing we haven't seen it
before now we you know we'll see guys
you know take on these huge boxing
fights and you it started the whole Jake
Paul and Logan Paul thing like all that
comes out of Conor's ability to dream so
damn big to fight Floyd Mayweather so
now it's it's common that one of these
boxing fights get announced like yeah
whatever we've seen it but at Connor at
the time it was unheard of man and his
come up and you're watching it and I
think the other Takeaway on that show is
you actually you see Connor and you
don't think he takes the game that
serious you know because he does all
these Antics and you find out about all
outside the Octagon
um issues he's having and that's kind of
overshadowed what he represented when he
was coming up and when you watching you
see how much he cares after the khabib
fight and Dana's coming in and uh this
is the other takeaway too you see that
Conor is not just a employee he's just
not a fighter you see they are Partners
the way he talks to Dana I went oh wow
I've never seen that because Danny comes
in the locker room after he loses khabib
and that remember khabib jumps into the
stands goes for Dylan Dennis it's chaos
and Conor's there and his family's there
and he his head's down and he's crying
and Dana goes man what happened can you
believe khabib jumped off and Connor
looks and goes I don't give a [__] about
any of that dude I lost man and he goes
no dude was it Dylan and Connor goes
you're not listening I do not care about
that dude I lost the better man one all
that stuff is [__] I don't care
about what just happened I care about I
lost the fight Dana and you can see
Dana's like oh okay I'm like man I've
never seen of ever in my life someone
speak to Dana that way not disrespectful
like like uh you know like like their
Partners sure it was fascinating man
really interested and I did see the
piece that you made on that where you
said hey I don't know if we'll see this
again in our lifetime and
ultimate the stuff Conor McGregor did
come on he walks into Madison Square
Garden the first time ever 17.2 million
dollar gate puts his hands behind his
back against Eddie Alvarez one of the
meanest nastiest guys ever I mean there
was some really special stuff uh done my
McGregor you made a point though Brandon
it kind of ties into what we're talking
about earlier with and gone are you
talking about you were talking about
Conor and that perhaps he's playing the
game and where that becomes really
relevant and how it ties back into
Francis if the UFC would have got that
deal done with Francis that would have
been a very slippery slope because now
they would have shown the world
go out hold out right get the
championship and hold it you're gonna
have a very hard time getting anybody to
not copy that model particularly if the
numbers come out we were advertised that
he was talking about Francis being
offered eight million to show the
biggest show that I personally am aware
of is uh Brock Lesnar's at 5.5 yep so
I'm just saying it would have been a
real lesson and while I say that though
you look at Jon Jones now I mean Dana's
time you know this is the savior and
he's done such a great job but I love
working with John John just got done
doing the Dana with Francis is currently
doing to him he took his ball he went
home he threw the belt out there he said
the hell with all of you you're gonna
pay me more he went to the public he
went to the media he they induct him
into the Hall of Fame he uses their
cameras in the Hall of Fame time to tell
the world Dana wants me back he's gonna
have to add some zeros to the check that
stuff can really come back and bite you
it can really set a a bad or weird
example and and I only offer that
because if that is in fact what Conor is
doing now Darren Tillis openly said
that's what I'm doing I got an injury
I'm going to take stuff I'm getting out
of the pool people are speculating
dillashaw's doing that they're wrong
villisha's not coming back but my point
is if one guy does it or even if if he
faints it if the rumor and belief that a
guy is doing it it can really catch on
it could be a domino effect and you've
got to stop that stuff man you got to
stop it right away agree 100 and Dana
does it to your point doesn't that's a
great Point Dana doesn't want to set
that as the standard like oh in order to
get things done this is how you do it so
this is why a lot of times people give
them so much pushback but they're
protecting the only thing they care
about which is the UFC brand no Fighters
bigger than the brand the only one
that's gotten even close and might might
have accomplished that again to the
point we're never gonna see it again is
Conor McGregor he's the one guy I've
only seen in my lifetime of watching a
million fights the the one guy who is
bigger than the brand
and I'll tell you what I mean this all
ties back in again Jon Jones and Connor
are about to cross paths one of my
favorite guys is Stephen I don't know
Steven terribly well but I respect
steepe I mean that is a first responder
that is a real life Action Hero like
guys that they put in comic books that
are firemen but he's also the badass oh
and by the way he's got the beautiful
wife and loves his kids that's not real
it's made up no it is real his name's
Stephen she lives in Cleveland right I
mean it's one of these really cool
things and I preface it with that
because I like to say speak nicely of
Stipe
there's something going on here okay
we're told that Stipe and Jones are
reserved for the main event in November
at Madison Square Garden we have been
told that correct to the point that
Pablo Lynch and and aspinall and
everybody else isn't even asking for
title shots they're standing back no
one's calling out Jones Jones isn't
going after anyone else that's what
we're told and we're also told that
those two are going to fight on though
uh December 10th of last year we were
also told that they were going to fight
on March 4th of this year now we're
being told it's going to be November
okay great the problem is this Conor
McGregor is set to enter the pool on
June 1st which is in about a week he
then according to usad had to do six
months that lines him up perfectly to
roll in and do the Madison Square Garden
card which is now being rumored so if
Conor is going to come in and bump your
main event which is your heavyweights
and then let's say that doesn't happen
so you bring them back but now now
you've made it obvious now you've made
your Heavyweight Championship at the the
mecca you've made it in afterthought so
now there's a new report that came out
we're going to do a huge show in
November but we're also going to do a
huge show in December which we would
think would allow for both of those main
events to take place but it is one of
these really interesting situations
usada says Connor needs 180 days usad is
wrong if that ever gets tested who
sought us wrong there is exemptions for
Conor and McGregor says I'm taking one
of those exemptions Dana's saying we've
got the date set I haven't revealed it
but we haven't said and I'll reveal it
through the ultimate fighter and usada
said he's not in the pool yet so all of
those things can't be true and that's
the fight that I've been waiting to see
McGregor versus USANA that's the fight
that I really want to see but USANA is
not going to like how this one turns out
you better read their own paperwork I
agree when you say the in what do do we
know what the exemption entails exactly
what the exemption would mean what like
I'm sure there has to be some sort of
regulatory testing it's not like you
can't they can't give an exemption he
just doesn't get tested right would it
be an exemption where where we announce
the date whatever in December and he we
start testing Nova is the exemption say
all right well we're not we're going to
bypass 180 days is that the exemption
and so this is where the debate comes in
this is where usada looks at one Clause
that says it's a retirement Clause
meaning if you leave the pool we don't
want you to go on a steroid holiday
that's a quote by them so we're going to
bring it back we're going to keep you in
there a while normally it's two months
but if you retire and come back we need
you for six months to make sure in case
you got something you got out of your
system but the effects and the residuals
are still there like you've got a
picogram or something so he's gonna stay
in there for six months let's do solder
rule that's the Clause that they're
turning to there's another Clause but it
says an extenuating Circumstance the
organization can bypass the entire
protocol and let me give you an example
of when that happens
we're we're in New York it's the week of
a show a main card match falls through
so we grab Chris Weidman who happens to
live there and can get over and get his
paperwork done we don't have time to
test him or moreover not at Chris
Weidman a guy that's never debuted in
the UFC he's not even in he gets his
contract on Tuesday he gets on a plane
Tuesday night he's in front of the
commission Thursday he's on the scale
Friday he's in the ring Saturday when
you're doing situations like that
they've got to be able to just bring you
in so most guys that are debuting in the
UFC have never been tested they're just
too new and so the UFC they put that
clause in and so that's what Connor's
turning to and the intent of that Clause
is for what I just described somebody
that was undiscovered a last minute a
replacement that's the intent of the
Clause but it's not what it says it says
that there are exemptions that can be
granted by the promotion this was a
fight soda did not want to give them
that and the UFC would not buckle and
they did give him that wow and do you
what kind of pushback do you think we
see from just the common fan base if
Conor gets that exemption do you think
he expects him in a negative way because
complete to be complete I don't give a
[__] get have him fight I don't care
what it is I don't care yeah I just want
to see him fight
I fully agree with that and I'll just
give you I'll give you an example but
Bob Bennett when he was running the
commission Travis Taggart who was
running usata Bob Bennett tested and
flagged Floyd Mayweather Floyd
Mayweather failed a test according to
the Nevada State athletic commission
usada comes in and does a post facto
exemption which is beyond overreach he
did not have it in place and usada did
an exemption so Bob Bennett is saying
okay that's between you all I don't I
don't know what you're doing here this
is my state where he's at it's my
fighter who's fighting I tested him and
I've got and he's hot and who sought to
step in and said then you could take us
to court but you're a state agency and
we're Federal you better meet with your
attorneys we're going to fight you on
this and Bob back down well it did not
do it if that would have been tested I
believe that Nevada and Bob would have
won but I only bring that to you because
what's the pushback gonna be I mean it
was pretty big Bob Bennett 17 years as
an FBI agent he's very respected Travis
Taggart he's very respect they called
each other's Integrity into question
this could have gotten really ugly
really fast but Bob backed down and
Travis then ultimately Travis one
without a court fight
so Floyd just to clear that up did not
officially did not fail any tests Bob
said he did but usada made it go away
yeah with this Con and the exemption his
fan base is so rabid and I think because
we keep hearing this and we're talking
about and the rest of the MMA media is
talking about and Dana's talking about
and answering questions I think people
at this point are almost sick to me like
we just want to see him fight I don't
know how much blowback there's gonna be
maybe from other Fighters some if
they're you know if they want to play
that game we'll see how that goes for
him but I don't think it's gonna be that
big of a deal I think we all just want
to see him fight at this point
yeah
yeah because I mean not to mention the
principle like let's go back to an
example would be UFC 200 think about
Mark hunt versus uh Brock Lesnar and
Hunt was Furious I mean it hurt his
feelings he thought that you know it was
underhanded against him he took him to
court that was very sincere by Mark hunt
Marcon did not like being in there with
a dirty athlete in a Marx defense he was
perfectly clean but I bring that to you
because that's not what Chandler's gonna
say he goes I don't care he's gonna say
what you're saying bro I don't care
whatever reason please get him in here
this is my knife this is the one I've
dreamed of this is the competition I
want but this is also the night of
business I want bring him in here if the
opponent's not complaining man it's
pretty hard to get anybody else to
listen agree uh what the interesting
story about side note with Mark Hunt is
my studios in Calabasas and there's this
um it's like a Whole Foods on steroids
and it's called erwan and um I go to
breakfast there every morning I have
like healthy juices whatever and I'm
walking in and I hear hey bro and I look
over it's Mark hunt he's there with his
lawyers he's there with his lawyers and
I go the hell are you doing Calabasas
dude he goes I'm here for the uh for the
court date with the UFC here's we're
flying to Vegas we stopped here to meet
with my lawyers and we're actually
leaving from here going to Vegas I go
that's still going on because you're
damn right man he goes you're damn right
and he's I don't know where they're at
on it now but it's all he's so upset man
and when I say dude he is so mad and you
know he wanted to come on the show
um and we're gonna figure it out
but I think there's he has so and I get
it I completely I understand why he's so
upset and he has so much resentment
against the UFC and Dana and the stuff
he says and he has every right to feel
that way but I was hesitant to bring it
on the show because I can't do a
two-hour show on you complaining about
this if that makes sense I I don't know
the ins and outs of it who's wrong who's
right the Brock Lesnar you did take the
fight signed the contract clearly blocks
on [__] you know so I don't it's tough
you know it's tough and I felt bad it's
just not what I do and I love Mark hunt
but dude I've never seen someone still
how long ago was that fight you'll see
200 to this day this is a few months ago
Furious man Fury yelling Furious Furious
yeah and he's sincere I mean and it's
hurting him it's costing him time it's
costing him money but he he just feels
he's on the right side of this and it is
really tough you know who would be at
fault for uh for Lesnar being dirty it
would seem Lesnar but there's no
mechanism where Lesnar has to pay so
he's chosen to put it on the UFC and I
just think that it's a tough one I mean
first off somebody's at fault every
legal situation is somebody's at fault
but then was that fault egregious I
think it's a really hard case I suppose
that's not really for here nor there you
shared something with me that it's still
going on but it is interesting I'll tell
you what some guys got put in that spot
because what you're talking about Brock
is being dirty we all know he's dirty so
if you have to go fight him it's a tough
thing Brian Stan got dealt a bad hand
with that and I can't remember them all
but I mean it was vandelay it was Chael
son and like there was a few guys in his
past they gave him a hard time oh man is
this all you're putting it with and you
know the poor Luke rockhold you know
Luke rockhold gets kicked he's on a roll
and and trtv tour got him or even this
one's the best example Jesus Christ man
that poor guy but when you talk about
somebody that's mad and is legit yeah
man bisping's pissed hell yeah in his
every right with with uh with the whole
Mark hunting I actually talked to my
lawyer about it it was just like what
like does he have to stand on he goes
the issue is is he went in the fight
complain about this but he did sign the
contract
he's like so to be tough because he did
perform knowing what he was signing up
for and did complete the contract and
did compete against Brock Lesnar now if
he would have held out said no I'm not
doing it until you do the test whatever
that's a different story but he did go
through with the act so that's where it
gets dicey I don't know I wish him luck
but that's a tough Hill to climb let's
move on brother you were talking about
so I said on the show I almost guarantee
you're getting hamzat versus Kamara
Usman it's kind of getting a little
smoke now I guaranteed it but you went
out and said you think we're gonna get
Izzy versus homzat
well I gotta tell you uh I actually ran
that one back I actually read that back
and I appreciate that you're up to speed
but let me tell you what my math was
when I did that okay it was for sure
Hamza versus Paulo Costa I got this from
Hamza I got this from polycast they're
going to fight Island they're going to
co-main event uh with Islam on top of
the bill taking on derush and Charles
Oliveira if those guys uh even ever
actually fight that's another
conversation so we know about it I mean
it's five months in advance and yeah you
know moving into 185 and Dana starts
kind of talking about that okay we got
it those guys are gonna fight and out of
nowhere and this is all in the same
night what I'm about to tell you this
timeline out of nowhere Paulo Acosta is
going to fight a guy that just called
out Mo nickel the guy is very good but
the only thing I know about him is he
called out oh nickel yeah which means
they broke up the chimaya fight now two
hours later there's a post fight press
conference and Dana reveals they've got
a new distribution partner in Australia
they're going to bring a show in August
and otisanya is going to Main Event so
I'm sitting back going okay Whitaker and
do policies are gonna go and fight and
now you've got Paulo coming over here
the only guy available
is shamaya and I don't know that they
want to put Jemiah but Izzy and Izzy's
backyard but it sure appears that
they're getting ready to do just that
then they booked Strickland and he's
with somebody else I mean there's
literally no players left on the board
then the very next day it gets revealed
to us that Kamara uzman is thinking
about coming up now Brandon that's a
problem though too and I'll tell you why
fight at 185 we don't even need to ask
is this a number one contenders fight we
will all know it you and I will come on
and we will tell our Aunt as soon as we
see that fights happening we'll tell our
audiences okay the winner here is going
to be fighting for the Bell we would
just know that the problem is Usman is
not going to fight Izzy and this isn't
like you know two buddies or two friends
this is much deeper this is Countryman
with a pride I mean this is probably the
greatest excuse for two guys not
competing that we've ever heard I don't
think anybody wants to get in the way of
that so we then get revealed Again by
Dana that Kumar does want to do the
fight he's dead serious he's lobbying
for it but he wants it to catch weight
now the only reason Kamara wants it as a
catch weight is he doesn't want to
become the number one Contender because
he doesn't want to go and fight adesanya
so I think that puts Dana in a little
bit of a hard spot of man that sure
seems like the fight to make but I can't
make it if you're not willing to move on
I need some all of you guys all of you
are interchangeable mediocrities I need
somebody to fight him my champion who
actually is a big draw I mean it's just
one of those spots so I don't know how
bullish I am I don't know how bullish I
am that I really think it's going to be
tremaya and arasania at the same time I
don't know anybody else to fight on and
I know as much as they want to do
duplicates they put to places with
Whitaker which is not much of a contest
that's gonna be fun and fun hype
Whittaker's gonna whip him agree and
nobody wants to see Bobby Knuckles and
arasania part three we didn't want to
see the second one
yeah do you have to you you make some
valid points the the yeah the the
biggest point is is when if you look at
that what top six they're all matched up
there's literally nobody for Izzy to
fight and they guarantee him that fight
in Australia
um
and and what they bypass the Camaro uh
uh homicide fight and give hamzat a
straight title shot 85 even though he's
never competed there that's a little
weird but it it also puts data in a
tough spot because he's like all right
we already announced he's fighting
Australia we signed this big new deal we
gotta get a juicy main event do policies
that's not happening right because he's
fighting Whitaker
um so yeah so all signs of a point that
it's Harm's not huh or a lot or does or
does uh this is ridiculous now we're
getting the weeds I was gonna say did
they say it's at middleweight could Izzy
go up to light heavyweight is it Jamal
Hill a possibility
sure sure and you gotta understand what
Master they're trying to serve and this
will always be denied this will be
denied till the end of time but you and
I are smart enough to know when you get
paid and you get asked to come into an
organization or come into a territory
you're probably also going to get an Ask
Of Who the main event is look the deal
is worth this to us if you can guarantee
him in the spot correct so and I only
say it because you know that will always
be tonight but it is very relevant and
if they did that and it sounds like they
did and it's with autosonya which it
sounds like it is who by the way when he
fought Bobby Knuckles the first time did
000 live in attendance the all-time MMA
record so if you're bringing them back
and this is who you want then that would
be Paramount finding the opponent for
him if you got to go up to 205 whatever
you have to do it would be Paramount
that you had him and if you just had to
grab Jemiah you know there's a few
different ways to do it but I I don't
think a co-main event or or even a
headline of of a smaller show between
shamayev and and Kamar uzman is as fun
as that would be for you and me the
world
I don't think that that's going to win
out over a contract that you just signed
with your new partners and they asked
you for auto sign in you said you could
deliver him that's a great Point yeah
I'm leaning towards you now my man the
other part is the other part to the
equation is
after you sign this new deal is he's uh
arguably the the face of the UFC you
know Connor's been out for a while so
I'd say Izzy's the biggest name now him
or John right
so if you're going to invest in the
Australian Market
Izzy versus a tough matchup for Izzy man
yeah Stylistics
it's kind of one of those it's kind of
one of those things but but if above
everything else your partner they they
want this guy on top of the bill
I mean just you got to do it at some
point Kane did that when he dropped the
strap to JDs on Fox it was a requests
for the whole reason that that Islam is
sitting out and waiting for fight item
is one of those things this is the guy
that we want this is the air apparent to
khabib who is our hero bring him out
here maybe he could be with corn man
it's one of those things and that's okay
that's that's their business but it's
also something that we need to observe
if we're if we're sitting here we're
trying to make our guesses and hedge our
bets it's important that we we do
understand it appears a guarantee of
Izzy on top of the bill has been made uh
I'm I'm excited more with you because
now you think about it the the Hamza
Kamara fight what's that really do let's
say it was announced it was at 70 maybe
they're they're talking about me at 70.
well we we know Kamal probably not don't
have much left in the tank as far as
fights at 70. probably don't have enough
that much in the tank in general whether
it's the 85 or 70. Hamza we know his
home isn't going to be at 70 for much
longer 70's a nightmare form 85 would
make more sense I would say all signs
are pointing you're right my man
yeah I mean it does really sound that
way and don't do police season Whitaker
are of the mind that they're in a
similar spot uh that we've got Benny
derush and Oliver in which is they're
going to fight in the Champions waiting
for you so you guys go get this settled
and then the Champions waiting for you I
know they're of that mind and I think
duplicates could be correct if if
duplicates is to win but it's gonna
depend how that looks how quick can you
turn around I mean that's not a whole
lot of time we're gonna do that fight
and get them ready and do a prester all
by August August is right around the
corner chance so it's just an
interesting spot you know we'll see what
happens I'm here in strong rumors that
the the Stephen Jones is going to go up
in flames and that Sergey Pavlich versus
Jones is happening in August uh I'm
hearing strong rumors on that it's
strong enough that I can tell you that's
at least being pursued I don't know
where they are in a green but that's at
least being pursued and if you did have
Partners in Australia you promised them
Izzy you said look I can't deliver but I
can bring you Jones and tablets are we
good they probably say yeah we're good
what now do you know what Brendan go
ahead I have if you don't mind me I have
to give Jon Jones credit for I really do
and that pains me I gotta give him
credit here because people have said he
was gonna fight Stipe and then he's
going to retire it's like well hold on
people let me remind you of one thing
when you talk about the mindset you talk
like Jon Jones doesn't have the courage
let me just remind you to be fair he
thought he was fighting Francis he
agreed to fight Stipe and he ended up in
there with surreal so when he is surreal
which is a pretty favorable matchup he
had agreed to Francis and he had agreed
to Stipe Jon Jones isn't going anywhere
and if the Stevie Goes Up in Smoke he's
already set off by the next best thing
you decide who it is oh you've decided
it Sergey then it's Sergi that's Jones's
real attitude and not for nothing he
deserves he deserves for people to know
that badass and also he's a badass he's
a badass badass straight up because yeah
because uh pavlovich is a nightmare not
dude when I watch him against Curtis
blades and of course blades my boy
trains my old team he demolished him
dude and I'm like and you look at the
he's this giant dude not a not not fat
it's like a Mack truck what's it six
Knockouts in a row it's not a it's a
tough night in the office for anybody
including Jon Jones not a big name
probably not gonna do great pay-per-view
numbers John's gonna have to carry the
card so for John when people are like oh
would you fight Pavlich when they asked
him he's like it doesn't make sense and
he's right as far as the business
doesn't make sense as far as his legacy
it makes sense but when you go back back
to your point that you know you're
hearing strong rumors that the the Stipe
Jon Jones fights Going Up in Flames that
has to be a steep a issue right nobody
wants to talk about that this has to be
a I I would assume why this fight hasn't
happened is a steepe issue is that fair
to say yes yes hey you say no one wants
to talk about it I'm included in that
when I did that whole diet driver I left
that and I don't know I don't know
what's going on there I talked to
steepe's wife she and I are pen pals I
haven't reached out to her in a period
of time but
I do need to remind you that stupid lost
the belt to Francis the knights Depot
lost the belt he weighed in at 233
pounds it was the second lowest he's
ever weighed in he was 231 for the
second D.C fight he waited at 233 pounds
so he thought Stipe that he was going to
be rematching for the title Francis a
true Trilogy fight he had every reason
to believe that but he went out and he
put on this he did exactly what Jon
Jones did he got on the protein he got
on the lift and he did everything he got
to 257. oh my 257 his wife said of
muscle she cooked for him he he did it
257 pounds that this is a wildly
different steep bag you're going to have
my interest if it's against Francis or
if it's against Jones that's also a
dedication to changes physiology was a
massive dedication so what is delaying
him I don't know Stephen was asked to do
this in December it didn't happen he was
told he could have it in March 4th and
fought for it he didn't get it and went
to surreal he came out on social media
made it very clear that he's going to
get it it's going to be uh International
fight weekend in July
Dana comes out and says we're moving all
the way to November which is it would
just seem as though even if there was
something wrong that we don't know about
yeah that's plenty of time so yes what
whatever is delaying this I don't know
but it is on his side that's true it
alarms me when I hear a guy puts on that
much weight John a little different and
we don't know how John looks at
heavyweight we really that Sarah gone
fight we learned nothing he he bully
beat down that guy went up not even a
great technical choke just a bully
[__] front joke gets him out of I
don't know how John's looks we don't
know when I hear Francis or when I heard
Stephen put on all that weight
just when I think about myself if I put
on that weight you're talking about a
completely different movement slower you
know stipe's known for his cardio that
probably goes out the window a little
bit I you know maybe he put on that
weight and was like his team's looking
at him you know in training like this
isn't good man this ain't good enough to
be John you're slower the cardio is not
there we rely on cardio and the pressure
but all this weight doesn't allow that I
don't I'm just I have no clue but it's
concerning it's definitely concerning
and I don't know either it's hard to
relate to I don't know what his finances
are I mean like he's got no gambling or
drug problem or a bunch of kids or
multiplies I mean he doesn't he was
every Champion for a while I would
assume he's stacked up quite a bit of
money and I only bring that because if
that's not the key driver and motivation
then they would defer to some of the
things that you're saying they would
defer to how are you going to look and
what's the Legacy and is this worth it I
am very strong of the mind if they can't
get this fight together one more time if
they're trying for November or December
that's being rumored if they're trying
if that falls apart they will never
revisit that and if Sergey comes in and
upset Shawn Jones just by example
they're not going to bring Stipe into
fight surgery I I think that if he
doesn't go through with the Jones fight
I think we can interpret that as a
retirement yep and it would seem as
though stipe's been retired for a period
of time we get tweets here and there and
we're told that he's the top Contender
and we've told he might even headline
Madison Square Garden but the rest of it
is kind of rumored we don't see much of
him we don't hear much of him he's a
very honest guy maybe that's why he
hasn't made any kind of commitment
because he doesn't want to follow
through I don't know what the back story
is there I know that he was offered in
December offered it in March begged for
it on social media in July and is now
saying I don't know if I'm going to show
up in November that's all accurate yeah
you blew my mind man yeah that's insane
and again we all love Stipe so yes the
elephant in the room like this seems
like it's a steep a problem and I'm not
saying maybe it's not even a problem
maybe he's like I just don't want to do
it I don't feel good at this heavy I
don't want to do it you know
yeah no it's a really tough one when he
says I can do it in July but I don't
know if I can do it in November I mean
it's a tough one because then we're left
to guess oh he doesn't feel well oh he's
sick or is you know injury family
members getting married I don't know
what it would be but you know when they
move it that direction it makes it tough
look aljo just went through this two
days ago aljo comes aljo's very funny
was way better than we knew by the way I
mean come on he told
combat athlete ever in Triple C aljo
comes out he says I don't know if I'm
going to fight no no Mali in August you
know my biceps bugging me I got to get
it worked on I don't know about fight
him in August that algal gets all worked
up and takes to social media and calls
him out for a July day oh that's kind of
where Hunter's like dude come on I gotta
use your own you said you'd be ready for
July I'm giving you more time this fight
is on and I'll just like yeah okay you
got me you got me yeah and I love it I
love it he tells sugar let's do this and
let's see if you're about that life
let's do in July and uh and she goes I'm
not I'll see you in August it's with the
whole algeo thing
um it's weird to disrespect that he gets
I get how some people with the Peter
yawn the way he got the belt right and
the legal knee and stuff like that but
at a certain point you gotta give this
guy his flowers man you're talking about
a complete badass and when you look at
the sugar uh Sean fight after being
headed to Judo and then doing what he
did to TJ again he gets Flack with the
TJ fight it's not his fault TJ had one
shoulder that has nothing to do with
aljo but again algo gets all the hate
for that he beats Henry sudo gets booed
in New Jersey and I don't know what he
has to do to win this these people over
if you beat sugar Shawn and go yeah but
he's just a striker and then you know
then you have marab there he refused to
fight marabis and go up to 45 before he
fights marab so I don't know what's
going to take to get the fan base behind
aljo and it's a shame man
and the the situation that you just laid
out runs parallel to Haney and Lomo and
let me tell you why the general belief
is that Lomo was the victim of a bad
decision so people are saying the only
way that Haney can correct this is to
give Lomo the rematch do the right thing
Lomo can take it from there he'll get
his belt back but then we could at least
look at Haney as somebody that did the
right thing hold on because that's what
they told aljo aljo we've only got a
couple of rules right I mean the night
that yawn and aljo part one that really
didn't set well with me I mean that was
the cover-up of the Year even though it
took place in February we've only got a
couple of rules don't bite the guy don't
poke him in the eyes and don't kick the
sumbitch when he's down he gets he gets
knees in the head when he's down the
referee has one remedy to that which is
a disqualification and unlike the WWE
The Bell can change hands with the
disqualification like everything was
done correctly there so they said you
got to rematch him so he says okay I'll
do it this is this is okay I'll do it he
goes out he rematches him he dominates
it's the first three rounds he throws
away the next two he leaves with his
belt but they didn't forgive him they
said if you do this rematch we will
forgive you they didn't forgive him they
didn't forgive him to the point that
they had to bring a guy out of
retirement because they knew he can't
beat this guy he's good but he can't
beat Henry and that was the General
belief and even at DraftKings he he was
a two to one dog against Henry and I
just bring to you he's better than we
knew that he was and you know I don't
want him to get pulled into something
trying to appease fans that's what
they're trying to do with Haney and Lomo
but that already happened with Sterling
he did Gone twice and the crowd still
didn't forgive him yeah I think without
Joe I don't know I don't know what's
going to take this poor guy I need I'm
sure you've talked him he's a great kid
man great kid that to your point he's
better than we thought with the with the
sugar Sean you know the the odds are on
his side so he if he does get that done
then he's probably gonna go to 145
because he him and Morocco refused to
fight each other at 45 you know I guess
if he beats volkonovsky people will
start giving his credit I guess that's
what's gonna take because look at
volkanovsky to your point volkanovsky
how long did it take for us to give him
his flowers I know I keep saying flowers
on this podcast but it is what it is how
long did it take to give vocalencias
flowers after the max Holloway it took
three max Halloween fights where he went
okay this guy's pretty good that's how
much we love Max Holloway sure and he
beat him three times it took three times
to finally the last one went all right
he beat him you know and then what he
did against machjev amazing amazing job
yeah and that's very common
this is a fan too I see something
I just had uh there Johnny at 185 takes
out Gengar Musashi I chalked that up to
Gengar had a terrible night and Johnny
had a great night Johnny Evelyn I really
didn't know that Evelyn was as good as
it turns out that he is it's one of
those things you've got to be reminded
of right success is something we as
people we need to be reminded of it very
often and
I I just I I only bring that to you
because sometimes you go out you clean
somebody up and you don't get the credit
it looks like you went out and you got
caught uh Rose did that Rose knocks out
Joanna so we go well let's rematch him
she obviously caught her and goes and
beats her again so then we do it to Rose
a second time she goes out and beats Wei
Lee there was nothing about Rose versus
Whaley part one that called for a
rematch there was nothing controversial
and there was nothing competitive we
rematched him oh by the way Wei Lee was
the favorite again because we just
dismissed it Rose has to go out and beat
her second time I only bring that
because it is very common when you see
something that they look so easy it
looks like he went through him so smooth
you almost chalk it up to you well you
had a good night and they had a bad
night instead of I'm witnessing
greatness I agree uh and for whatever
reason I'm not away with Charles
Oliveira I don't know what's going to
take man I just I always pick against
him for whatever reason I'm I don't know
what's going to take to to get me over
not that he needs me as a fan but I just
I always pick against him for some
freaking reason man every fight I don't
know what it is him and Benny is very
interesting you know they're talking
about rematch in this one now they're
going to do it in Salt Lake but I want
to bring one thing to your attention
which is unless you're a title fighter
or main event by policy you're not a
five round fight now I realized that
Uhaul Mohammed and Gilbert Burns just
broke that rule I don't like that I wish
they wouldn't have broken that but I
will share with you Oliveira and Benny
has been booked twice this is now the
third time the first two times they were
booked was a main event which means it
was scheduled for five rounds now it's
going to be brought down to three and
that's a very different fight when you
were Benny to Rouge and you're one of
the few guys who can weaponize Pace yeah
you can put something on a guy that most
people will just can't hold up it's very
different when Charles only has to hold
up for 15 minutes I just bring that to
you because it's a different fight I
don't like that about our sport by the
way I mean I think it should all be the
same like the Super Bowl is it isn't
five quarters because it's the Super
Bowl or something like that you know
it's this is how you play the game 100
meter race we don't run 103 meters
because it's for the championship I just
don't like it do them all five or do
them all three I I don't like the CH and
that's not the hill that I want to die
on but I thought I'd bring it I don't
like it I'm with you some certain fights
when they when it is only three rounds
my God I wish I had two more so we get a
clear winner so I'd be on the side of
making them all five but some of those
prelims would be long man and I have to
watch all that [__] so I'll just keep it
at three you know
um can you convince me why because you
know the the media and the public are
kind of opposed this can you convince
the the listeners why your boy Kobe
Covington who we both love and admire
why he deserves this title shot when you
when you look at the resumes and you'll
get the other competition with Muhammad
who probably deserves it you know on
paper a little more you look at his
strength of schedule and you look at
Kobe Compton he's fallen on maybe some
hard times there
you know yes I mean I I got to start
with this well Hall definitely deserves
it Muhammad has done enough I think that
lahal needs to play up a little bit more
the fact that I'm the one that stopped
Leon's win streak he doesn't have to say
beat him he didn't beat him but he did
stop the win streak I think that that
was a really good angle that he could
have done by the way Leon didn't want
Kobe he wanted to fight lahal but Leon's
problem is he said no I'm not going to
fight Colby he's not gonna fight God I'm
not gonna fight he didn't go after blah
Hall and he should have he should have
said this is the guy that stopped my win
streak and he started because he cheated
and he poked me in the eye I haven't
forgotten that I poke or vice versa
however that ended I'm just saying they
could have really played into that more
and they did it it was a Miss he had Leo
on his side if you're ever going to turn
an idea down you've got to offer a
suggestion I I follow politics very
close and the most annoying politicians
are the one that say no to someone
else's idea if you're going to say no
offer a suggestion when they don't do
that it hurts and that's what happened
with Leon now as far as head to head
Colby uh versus Muhammad rankings do
matter and rankings aren't Fair they're
really not but the rankings committee
has put Colby in front of Muhammad and
ultimately that is going to matter and
when you have Kobe I mean Kobe was an
interim Champion he never lost and one
day woke up and wasn't interim Champion
like this isn't a riddle that happened
to him yeah Colby fought and defeated
the BMF Champion but there was every day
that Colby woke up and he was the BMF
champion and I'll also remind you when
Leon went and got a fight Kamara which
he definitely earned but when he did
that he leaped from colby colby was
ranked in front of Leon but we all
understood Colby's done this twice he's
come up short we get we got to go to
someone else so there was an argument
that was made right after that fight was
done that Colby flew out he was you know
last minute and he weighed in as The
Ultimate Fighter and Joe Rogan said his
name on camera and therefore he's the
guy that's like no that's never been the
argument he's always been ranked in
front he's been the clearest number one
contender in our sport he can't fight
for the belt because he already did
twice it's a really unique situation but
here you are and I I mean I do think
like if volkanovsky left the weight
class just by example he leaves or gets
me obviously Max is going to go in he
showed a gap between himself and
everybody else uh I do think that Kobe's
the right move I do and I think that
Mohammed definitely has done everything
right to to get in there as well
sometimes there's more than one right
idea yeah I think there's definitely
more than one right idea and I also
think UFC again as a business is going
Leon's not the biggest pay-per-view star
this can be a big pay-per-view for us I
assume they do it maybe in England
wherever they're going to do it even if
they do it here but they're looking at
going if Kobe's champ we know Kobe we
know the analytics Kobe brings a fan
base Kobe brings even the haters but
people are paying to watch this guy
fight that's who we need as our champion
because if because Kobe Muhammad
unfortunately probably doesn't do great
so the UFC as a business is going you
know Kobe if he becomes champ which
matches up pretty well against Aaron
Edwards and then we do Muhammad Muhammad
is going to get his which is going to
take a little longer because we can make
money off Kobe being Champion we can't
make money off Leon Edwards and Muhammad
we put those two together it it just
doesn't now is it the right thing to do
probably not but still Kobe is the guy
that can get eyeballs on those fights
and that's why they're doing it I think
and Brandon think about part of this
would be and by the way Colby and mosman
all were both gone for a meaningful
period I don't know if that whatever
they have going I don't know what to
call that whatever that is I don't know
if that's precluded them from fighting I
mean we really haven't heard from either
one till just now that that's a side
thought I want to tell you this so
imagine being Dana White so you give
Leon the opportunity he doesn't have a
huge fan base he's not a huge main event
or he's not a big drop but you're gonna
give him the opportunity he throws the
head kick heard around the world now
you're going to go to a true Trilogy and
you're gonna wait you're gonna book a
menu in his backyard so he can come in
and have that fit to that dream that
everybody has he gets to be the huge
star in front of everybody you do it oh
by the way you give him a million
dollars and he goes out and wins now
you've done all these things for this
guy you changed this guy's life and the
first time you ask him for something he
tells you no that night at the press
conference 40 minutes after you made
this guy a multi-millionaire in an arena
that you booked just to make him that
you say I want you to fight Colby and he
he tells you no I'm just saying imagine
that because that's Dana's life every
single day man these guys they get in a
position and they turn the gun back on
the company and I would have to think
that's very frustrating
yeah very frustrating and it also is
probably not the way to do it either you
know we've seen this in Woodley Al Joe I
wouldn't put him in that category yet
he's getting there I also think these
guys need to realize it really doesn't
work like that I don't know how long
it's going to take people to realize
that because even without Joe when data
announced a fight now Joe Ray Longo and
aljo came out and goes we didn't agree
to the fight it's like you don't
understand that's when the fight's
happening it is that's when the fight is
happening we announced it's happening
what they say August and Boston sugar
Shawn and Al Joe that's we made the
announcement that's when you are
fighting so for these guys no I never
agreed to that you but you did now you
know with Leon it's like no Dana said
Kobe is next that is what is happening
dude to your point now if you have
something else you can pitch us and we
can roll with it even even if he did the
whole you know he stopped my losing
streak the UFC's looking at go no we
need to get Kobe in there that's who
you're fighting that's what's happening
fellas you don't really have a say in it
until you get to that level of Conor
you've put enough you know hours being a
champion you really don't have that
leverage you just don't that's the game
and Deals get made Brendan like I don't
I don't know that this is what happened
but just to give you a scenario
mosbadol was the second biggest star in
the whole sport I mean just right
underneath Conor and for reasons unknown
they thought it was a good idea to put
them in a five round Main Event against
Colby which was going to be his
Kryptonite however this is what they did
in moswell made tons and tons of money
so Colby's looking at going guys I'm
doing the meeting I'm doing the Press
I'm going to do half of this work and by
the way I'm gonna win it's making four
times when I'm making they go Colby just
go through with it if you win here you
get the title fight you win the title
fight you're back on pay-per-view points
right it's one of these things and so
you've got to honor some of those things
you might remember Lorenzo personally
told Gustafson fight Rumble Johnson what
no matter what happens you will fight
for the belt next now Lorenzo thought he
was going to win but he still told him
you'd fight Johnson whatever happens
you'll fight for the belt Johnson
knocked him out in the first round gusts
Us in they woke him up and put him in
there for a title fight just because
they honored those two well you know but
it's one of those things where if you
are around long enough kind of like you
and me you start to see this and when
something doesn't quite right it's like
okay but this was his he got something
down the road if I like the flags in
football I'll ask for something and you
know they're really good I mean UFC does
a great job of of do say they will do
whatever they say and I think that maybe
there could be something like that with
the Kobe situation that goes back five
six eight months even I think there
could have been a deal made I think even
with the deal and you know you'd know
better me and I don't want to get in the
weeds too much here but even with his
lawsuit and you know pursuing legal
charges against MOS of it all that just
all went away and I you know I I do
think the UFC's going all right Kobe if
you go through with this we can't fight
Mazel at all which we want to do back
then you're not fighting until this all
clears up get rid of that stuff you get
a Top Shot guaranteed title shot
sure who wouldn't do it yeah I think
that's part of it too I think that they
did step in and try to do that Hey
listen we're seeing that right now I
think the whole world knows about it but
it wasn't big news which surprised me
and that is
Islam Uncle chip gets called out by Dan
hooker because of a nurse that happens
to be uh in Perth that says I came to
the room and I I Beed monkey well that
is grossly against the rules now there's
no violation of a rule if there isn't a
challenge right you can roll right
through a stop sign and not stop if the
cop doesn't ticket you you're never
gonna have to answer for it it's one of
these situations so what do you do what
do you do when Perth has its own
commission that would be outside Abu
Sada what do you do if you have a nurse
Whose license making a statement what do
you do if you are a team being
challenged
to prove this by the hometown guy well
you're gonna have to lawyer up you're
gonna have to come back to Perth you're
going to be tied up in knee-deep in red
tape for a period of time and it's not
really a question of did he do it or not
he's he's half naked the next day on TV
we can zoom in and see that it was done
or you could be the organization and
step in and say please don't file that
please don't even talk about this in
exchange B Rodriguez I'll do the rematch
are we good yeah we're good they give a
walk out of the room so to your point
could have that happened with Colby and
joy yeah sure it could and I don't think
that it would be wrong I wish that
somebody would step in I really don't
like those two guys fighting I really
don't they used to be good friends might
as well help Kobe a lot early on and I
know that got paid back but I wish that
they got along I'll tell you that I
think with the markshev and the IV thing
the only the thing you got kind of swept
on the rug pretty quickly there too I
think Ali came on said said no you can
actually you have there's an exemption
where guys can't get IVs which was news
to me
yes well I I know that I know that he
said that if you go and read the rule I
think you'll come to a different opinion
one thing that I don't know that Ali
knew and one thing I'm not sure anyone
knew usada didn't have full Authority
they had oversight but you then also had
to go by that of the commission and it's
not whichever is looser it's whichever
is Tighter and the Commission in
Australia very explicitly talks about
rehydration you cannot for rehydration
between the weigh-in and the fight do an
IV and they list and they really cover
their bases very well there
um so what so what's so what leg does
Ollie have to stand on because also to
your point too with usaba that's United
States anti-toping not uh yeah they
would still have authority they would
still have authority much like the
Olympic Games they could go overseas
they would still have authority but um
uh in the United States part just means
they work on funds uh directed by our
United States Senate but but I would
just tell you when Ali made the state
this is my guess I didn't ask Ali but my
guess is he looked at the Osama Rule and
decided that was okay my guess is he did
not know that there was then an
Australian Rule now this got enacted
just to bring the UFC there you might
remember the night it's supposed to be
Kelvin gaslin versus Izzy it ended up
being Izzy versus Anderson great night
just to have that there they formed this
entire commission and that commission is
more stringent than usada on this issue
and we always default to the more
stringent not the less so I don't think
that Ali knew that that existed and
USANA does have a problem they will let
you IV you just not very much what they
don't say is how often you can do that
so if I can do 10 season why don't I do
10 CC's take it out of my arm put it in
the other arm and do 10 take it out put
it back in this arm like for the rule
you could get cutesy and do that it's
just that one setting can only be a a
certain amount and that's the plush EPO
I mean Lance arms usada taught the world
how to beat them nobody really
understood the way to get EPO growth
through your system is to IV it and
flush it with an IV we learned that when
they banned the ID so you know USANA
taught people how to beat them damn it
that's so interesting man and I I didn't
think about that I forgot about that
yeah it completely went away yeah yeah
that's all that lands did nobody could
figure out how answers be that even the
fellow cyclists like man how are you
doing I see they test you all the time
well his answer was he flushed it with
an IV he he was kind of the first to the
party to realize that you can get the
effects and the benefits long after it's
out of your system and that was the big
issue with the picogram by the way like
you know they tried to say a picogram
wasn't enough to cheat and that might be
one way to look at it but that's not the
way it ever should have been framed it's
not a picogram in your system it's a
picogram left in your system that is
that is a completely different
conversation which they know which is
why they went in the other direction I
just bring that to you that you know
those rules can be looked at looked at
pretty close or you go make a quick deal
tell him to be Rodriguez tell them we'll
do this down the road which is easier
for everybody sure and then also with
the Jon Jones things didn't he get
exonerated was it uh that uh didn't Bow
high Towers on said in the current rules
and regulations that Jon Jones wouldn't
have tested hot under the current
testing
cocaine charge in there but they don't
test for Street jobs so when John played
hot for cocaine he actually was not in
violation he took a PR hit but he wasn't
actually in violation through the sport
like his license was never in Jeopardy
and uh yeah he did come out and say and
I didn't go back to see how true that
was he did come out and say though he
would have been exonerated under the
current rules
I mean I you know I guess that worked
you know but because because at the time
those weren't the rules but yeah that
works for me uh jail dude you're my
you're my favorite person to talk to man
you know this brother I appreciate
everybody hey can I tell you something
because I feel like you're giving me the
boot I gotta tell you this was awesome
thank you Brendan and I you know what
Brian Callan treated me so nicely in
Portland and that's because of you
that's because he respects you and our
relationship he treated me so nicely
brought my whole family in I brought you
know I had five or six people it's kind
of a scumbag move he's offered me
tickets
I couldn't turn it down he brings us in
he treats us great then he brings us in
the back into his green room
talks to us was nice to everybody spent
some time with Britney's Dad one on one
it was it was just a cool move and it's
because because of you so of course you
know I love the hell out of you man uh I
saw you on I'll leave you on this you're
on Instagram uh benching you're saying
doing the incline press yes you look in
shape my man I'm looking at Chelsea
right now you look pretty shredded there
any what's going on here man it's just
you just want to try and be healthy
what's going on here goes back to Jon
Jones Jon Jones
no one should listen to me he said that
guy has boobs now I'm not saying that's
an accusation okay it was more of a
observation but either way I didn't like
it hey I got HCG going through these
bands and I'm working on that bench
every day these boobies are going away
then that's incline my Toros before you
know it and that's incline Daddy get to
get rid of those tits bro and yeah and
I'll tell you what fat shaming works man
I get online all the time your boy's in
shape man Pat shaming works
it does work all right brother I
appreciate you talking you look great
man thank you for this